السلام عليكم ورحمه الله اهلا بكم في هذه
الوقفه التحليليه اليوميه مع ما يجري في
قطاع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
غزه في وقت يشتد فيه القصف الاسرائيلي على
خان يونس تقدم قيادات عسكريه اسرائيليه
صورتين مختلفتين استوقفت المسافه بينهما
المتابعين لتطورات الحرب الاسرائيليه على
غزه الاولى قدمها المتحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي وقال فيها ان الجيش لم يتمكن
بعد من الحاق الهزيمه بمقاتلي حركه حماس
في شمال قطاع غزه جنتان كونريكوس برر ذلك
بان العمليه العسكريه وتضاريسها القتاليه
في قطاع غزه صعبه وذكر المتحدث بان صناع
القرار في اسرائيل اخبر الجميع ومنذ
البدايه ان القتال مع حركه حماس سيستغرق
وقتا طويلا هذا الوقت تحدث عنه كذلك وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي جلنت قائلا ان الحرب ضد
حماس وبقيه فصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه في
غزه قد لا تنتهي قبل شهرين في المقابل
جاءت تصريحات قائد سلاح المدرعات
الاسرائيليه هشام ابراهيم مختلفه اذ قال
ان القوات البريه الاسرائيليه على وشك
الانتهاء من اتمام مهمتها في شمال قطاع
غزه مضيفا في نبره مفعمه بالتفاؤل
قائلا انهم بداوا بتوسيع المناوره البريه
في اجزاء اخرى من القطاع بهدف القضاء على
حماس حماس اكدت من جهاتها ان مقاتليها
وجهوا ضربات نوعيه وكبيره لتجمعات من
القوات الاسرائيليه في مناطق بشمال قطاع
غزه خلفت قتل وجرح بالعشرات في صفوفها
حماس كما فصائل اخرى من المقاو
اشارت الى انها رشقت مواقع ومدن وبلدات
اسرائيليه برشقات من صواريخها في تاكيد
منها على فاعلياتها الميدانيه رغم شراسه
الحرب الاسرائيليه
عليها معنا اليوم في هذه الوقفه هنا في
الاستديو اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي ومن القدس الدكتور
محمد هلسه الاكاديمي والخبير بالشان
الاسرائيلي اهلا بضيفنا نبدا باللواء فايز
الدويري الان ال ال الاوضاع مشتعله في خان
يونس وفي نفس الوقت الاسرائيليون ليسوا
جازمين فيما يتعلق بانهم حسموا الامر في
الشمال كيف نفهم هذه الصوره يعني اولا
التصريحات
المتضاربه لها دلالتها اولا لو كانت مبنيه
على
حقائق مسقطه على الارض لما كان هذا
التباين ان يتم التباين بصوره صارخه اذا
هناك خلل انا اميل الى التصريح الذي يتحدث
حدث عن صعوبه الحسم وليس الى التصريح
التفاؤلي لماذا لانه عندما بدات
الهدنه جاءت في الوقت المناسب بالنسبه
لجيش الاحتلال قد يكون لها ظروف التي فرضت
هذا التوقيت لكن كانت قوات جيش الاحتلال
قد وصلت الى نقطه السمت النقطه القصوى من
تحقيق الانجاز وتوقفت وتعثرت فجاءت هذه
الهدنه استخدم مصطلح اعاده او ما اطلقنا
عليه مصطلح اعاده الانتشار والتموضع وجاءت
الصور الجويه لتكشف ذلك وجاءت في على
ثلاثه مراحل 11 14 24 من نوفمبر الماضي
وانسحبت هذه القوات تم اعاده تجميعها تم
اعاده قراءه المشهد توصلوا الى قراءه وانا
اتحدث منبعد تحليلي توصلوا الى قراءه ان
الاستمرار في معركه شمال غزه هو مضي على
الوقت واستمرار خاسر الرهان على رهان خاسر
ان يتم تحقيق انجازات لكن سنجرب في مكان
اخر لعله ما اخفق فيه في الجزء الاول ننجح
به بالجزء الثاني هنا جاء م ما يؤيد هذا
التوجه تصريح القسام امس انه الجيش
الاحتلال سحب 70% من قواته من المنطقه
الشماليه هذا يعني انه سحب حجم فرقتين
وابقى على فرقه لهذا السبب القتال في
الشمال الان تنفذ فرقه الفرقتين اللي تم
سحبهم نحن نتحدث عن 25 م مسافه
وبالتالي مجرد العوده الى نقاط الحشد
الجديده تحتاج هذه المسافه دعمها بفرقه من
الاحتياط العملياتي فاصبح لديه ثلاثه فرق
في الجنوب وفرقه في الشمال اي اربعه فرق
تعمل
الان ماذا يجري في الشمال يعني بعجاله حتى
نثبت من حيث المبدا وقبل الحديث انا اقول
وكان من بعد تحليلي مبني على المتابعات
لحظه بلحظه لياتي بواح كيل متر مربع من
قطاع غزه من اصل 362 م م مربع يسيطروا
عليه لياتي بذلك لا يوجد الان هناك
مرتكزين يدعم ما
اطرح بيت حانون جحر الديك وصلوها في اليوم
الاول من الحمله البريه الاولى وهي الان
هي شد ضراوه وقتال واحداث تدمير الان في
في الجنوب هناك مناوره جديده اذا اتيح
الوقت سنتحدث عنها اذا دعني اقول الجيش
الاسرائيلي فشل
بالمقاربة من انه حسم الاولى يعني هل
تعتقد بانه بامكانه ان ان يتحرك في في في
جبهتين بنفس
الضراوه بالضبط ولذلك انا لا اخذ الامر
فقط من باب المقاربه العسكريه فقط نعم
للميدان كلمه لكننا تعودنا وتعلمنا بان
الحرب هي صوت السياسه العاليه وبالتالي
حينما اقرا مشهد ما يجري لا اعزله عن
الاعتبارات الاخرى اعتبارات الح الداخليه
الاسرائيليه اعتبارات الحاله المتناقضه في
في داخل المستوى وكبينه الحرب اعتبارات
المنظومه الدوليه وضغطها واعتبارات الموقف
الامريكي هذه كلها تنعكس على ما يجري في
الميدان ولا يمكن قراءه المشهد معزل عنها
يعني المرحله الاولى حينما انتهت عند
الهدنه بالتاكيد لم تكن قد حسمت ولذلك او
حسمتها اسرائيل عسكريا وذلك ظهر من خلال
ظهور كتائب القسام وا اذرع المقاومه
المختلفه وتحركها فيها وظهر كذلك من خلال
بدء الجوله الثانيه في تصدي وظهور يعني
مواقع
مختلفه المناوشه في المقاومه الان على كل
ونحن ونحن نتحدث الان دكتور هلا س نتابع
هذه الصور التي تاتينا مباشره من من غلاف
غزه واضح ان الاجواء هناك ايضا
ليست بالهدوء الذي ربما يظن طالما ان جبهه
خان يونس سئله
تفضل انا اعود الى النقطه الفصل في هذا
الموضوع لو ان القضيه محض مواجهه عسكريه
بعيده عن الاعتبارات المختلفه لكنا يعني
ربما هذا الحديث يجري بصوره مختلفه لكن
هنالك اعتباران مهمان جدا يتنازع المجتمع
الاسرائيلي في هذه المرحله الاعتبار الاول
اي وهما يسيران بشكل
متصادمتان وهما هذان الاعتبار مساران يعني
يعني يعيشهما العقل الاسرائيلي ويتخبط
فيهما بشكل مجنون لانه اذا قلنا بان
اسرائيل ذاهبه الى الحرب معناته ان
اسرائيل قد تخلت عن اسرها وقد يعني
اي تعيش عقده الان المواجهه التي تجري
وتتعاظم في داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي من
ذوي الاسرى واليوم يخضع نتنياهو و كبنه
الحرب لدعوات هؤلاء للقائه وبالتالي
الاولويات تتقدم وتتاخر لا يعني قناعه
مطلقه ولا موقف مطلق في داخل الكابينه
الحرب ولا في داخل الحكومه ككل من طبيعه
الاهداف التي تذهب اليها هذه المواجهه
وبالتالي هنالك تغير في الاولويات بين
لحظه واخرى جزء مما يضخ في الفضاء العام
الاسرائيلي بان هدف هذه المواجهه ليس فقط
الذهاب الى انتهاء حكم حماس وا السيطره
على قطاع غزه نسمع بين الفينه والاخرى
بانه هدفها هو تحسيين ظروف واشتراطات
المقاومه في موضوع التفاوض على الاسرى
يعني مع ذلك دكتور ه يعني كيف نفهم هذا
التضارب في التصريحات الاسرائيليه يعني
اوردنا بعضها ولكن دعني اذكر بمقتطفات
اخرى عندما ياتي قائد سلاح المدرعات هشام
ابراهيم يقول نحن على وشك انجاز المهمه في
شمال غزه يعني ليست منتهيه بينما ياتي
المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي جوناتان
كيركوس اشرنا اليه قبل قليل قال قال لم
نهزمه كليا عسكريا في الشمال ولكننا
احرزنا تقدم جيدا تصريحين متناقضان ياتي
وزير الدفاع يعطي نبره اخرى يقول نحن
ذاهبون الى الى الجنوب وسيكون مصير مقاتلي
حماس هناك اسوا مما حصل في الشمال بما
يعني انه في الشمال حقق نصرا مبينا
يعني هل هناك اضطراب في على على هذا
الصعيد
اعلاميا ليس اعلاميا الاضطراب والخلافات
تعصف بكل مناحي الحياه الاسرائيليه اذا
كان الكابينت الاسرائيلي واهم ركنين فيه
رئيس الوزراء ووزير حربه لم يستطيع ان
يلتقيا في مؤتمر صحفي مشترك ولا يستطيعان
اليوم الاعلامي الاسرائيلي يتحدث هما لا
يستطيعان ان يلتقيا في داخل غرفه واحده
اسرائيل رفعت شعار منذ بدايه هذه المواجهه
تقول فيه انه معا ننتصر اليوم يتبين بانه
اركان اساسيه في هذه المواجهه لا يستطيعا
ان يكونا معا فكيف يعني تريد ان تكون
المواقف منسجمه في اطار هذه الاجواء التي
تجري ولا تنسى ايضا بانه في الحكومه ايضا
هنالك عناصر متناقضه جدا هنالك النقيض
ونقيضه هنالك مواقف تظهر بين الفينه
والاخرى تشي بطبيعه الخلافات الداخليه في
داخل هذا المجتمع ونذهب ايضا الى داخل
المجتمع الاسرائيلي المجتمع الاسرائيلي
ذاته ايضا نعيش هذا الصراع بين من يعني
يريد الذهاب في هذه المواجهه من خلال هذا
اليمين الذي يمثله بينغ فيروس مترش الى
حدودها القصوى ومن يريد الان اعتبار قضيه
الاسرى هي الملف العم الاساسي الاوحد الذي
يجب ان تلتف حول المواقف الاسرائيليه
واعتبار الحرب ملفا او يعني هدفا ثانويا
هذه كلها جزء من المشهد الذي يحكم تقدم
الاسرائيلي او مواقف الاسرائيلي في الحرب
وفي السياسه في كل ما يجري نعم اذا اذا
كانت اذا اذا سلمنا بما قالته اكسيوس لواء
فايز الدويري نقلا عن مسؤولين اسرائيليين
تقول اسرائيل تحتاج الى دعم واشنطن اذا
ارادت ان توسع المعارك الى الى خان يونس
يعني ما دلاله ذلك اذا كان اصلا الضوء
الاخضر الامريكي قائم منذ البدايه الى
الان يا سيدي يعني المساعده الامريكيه في
كل الابعاد في الابعاد السياسيه
ودعم التوجهات
الاسرائيليه زيارات زياره الرئيس بايدن
زياره وزير الدفاع الزيارات المتكرره
لوزير الخارجيه وفي المره الاولى قال انا
احذر الى هنا كيهودي وليس كوزير خارجيه
الجسر
الجوي الذي يمد اسرائيل حركه حاملات
الطائرات والحشد القوه ارسال 2000 جندي من
قوات الدلتا حضور ري ستار جنرال الى غرفه
الع هذا كل هذا يعني امريكا جزء من الحرب
وليس ليس داعمه يعني قد اتحفظ على كلمه ان
امريكا داعمه امريكا راس الحرب فيما يجري
سياسيا وعسكريا وبالتالي بدات المستودعات
في في دوله الاحتلال في الكيان الاسرائيلي
ينفذ وبالتالي الجسر الجوي على مدار
الساعه اذا امريكا هي حاضره في الحرب لا
بل ابعد من ذلك حتى في المنظومات
الاستخباريه ليس امريكا هناك العديد من
الدول تزود الاقمار الصناعيه طائرات
الاستطلاع ما شابه ذلك فبالتالي اسرائيل
في مازق اسرائيل في مازق ربما ربما هذا ما
يبرر ما ما نقلته اكسيوس ايضا نقلا عن
المسؤول اسرائيلي بان اسرائيل لا تمانع
العوده للحديث عن صفقه تبادل يعني يفترض
ان صفقه التبادل هذه طويت بالعوده الىى
المعارك يا سيدي من وجهه نظر
عسكريه اسرائيل في مازق بعد 59 يوم لم
تحقق اي انجاز يقدم الى الشعب
الاسرائيلي ياتوني بانجاز عسكري واحد اذا
اعتبروا ان عمليه تهجير 1.9 مليون من اهل
غزه تدمير 80% من المباني انجاز فهذا حديث
اخر اما
كمعركة لا ياتوني بقول انه استطعنا الدخول
هو يستطيع الدخول لكن هل سيطر هذا هو
السؤال نعم هناك ايضا مساله اخرى دكتور
هلسه اشار اليها اكثر من من محلل اسرائيلي
ولكن هنا ساكتفي فقط بما كتبه جدعون ليفي
في في هارتس البارحه يقول هنا انا اقتبس
يقول اسرائيل مستمره في القتل من دون توقف
فقط من اجل تحقيق اهداف ثمت شك في ان انها
ممكنه التحقيق واذا تحققت فانها لن تحل
شيئا بمعنى انه اكثر من كاتب ليس فقط
جدعون ليفي لان لديه دائما مقاربه نقديه
ولكن اكثر من كاتب يقول اسرائيل تحارب
بقسوه بعنف لكن لا تملك تصور لا لما تريده
و ولا لما ستفعله هل هذا ما يشك ما يفسر
هذا الاضطراب وهذا الارتباك
اي جزء مما قاله ايضا يقول نقاد وكتاب في
العالم الغربي قيل بانه ما يحرك اسرائيل
كمجتمع وما يحرك جيشه هو الغضب وشهوه
القتل وانه هذا لا يقود الى الانتصار
ناحوم برنياع في دعوت احرونوت كتب بالامس
وهو صحفي مشهور قال بانه دعونا نكون
واقعين الدخول الى خان يونس لن يشكل
انتصارا ودعونا يعني اي نركز على الاهداف
القابله للتحقيق قضيه الاسرى دعونا نعود
الى قضيه الاسرى
ونركز في موضوعها ال الصوره في في داخل
المجتمع الاسرائيلي اي مع كل ما يجري منذ
بدايه هذه المواجهه يعني حركها اعتباران
الاعتبار الاول انه هذا المجتمع عنده
استعداد ان يتحمل جزء كبير من الخسائر
التي تحدث وان يذهب الى حرب الاستنزاف هذه
لا اعلم متى يعني تنتهي قصيره ام طويله
لكن شريطه امران الشرط الاول ان تكون
هنالك جمله من الاهداف الاستراتيجيه
القابله للتحقق الممكنه التحقق الشرط
الاخر ان تكون هنالك قياده سياسيه قادره
على تحقيق هذه الاهداف السياسيه اذا عدنا
للبند الاول لشرط الاول نجد بانه الاهداف
السياسيه الكبيره التي طرحت وما زالت تملا
الفضاء الاسرائيلي القضاء على حماس
استعاده الاسرع ومنع تكرار ما حدث في
السابع من اكتوبر ايا منها لم يتحقق حتى
هذه اللحظه وحتى في ملف الاسرع جزء من
الاسرائيليين يقول ان اسرائيل اتت مرغمه
الى الصفقه ولو كان بيدها ان تحرر اي من
الاسرائيلي بمنطق القوه لفعلت لكنها اتت
مرغمه الان في البند الاخر اسرائيل لا
تعتقد هنالك غالبيه كبيره جدا في داخل
المجتمع الاسرائيلي لا يعتقد بان هذه
القياده الاسرائيليه الان يعني مخوله او
قادره على تحقيق هذه الاهداف الاستراتيجيه
لذلك التخبط الذي يجري واستبدال الاهداف
وضخ يعني مواقف متناقضه متضاربه من
المستوى السياسي والعسكري هوياتي في هذا
الاطار لانه في فراغ استراتيجي كبير جدا
لا يمل الا هذه الشعارات الكبيره ومنعم
نفهم حاله التناقض التي تجري في داخل
وربما هذا ما جعل زعيم المعارضه يدعو الى
مره اخرى الى
استقاله نتنياهو ان انه لم يعد يحظى
بالثقه وربما
حتى استئناف محاكمته ربما مؤشر على ان
الامر ليس بال السلاسه التي كان يظنها هو
على الاقل الان
وا خان يونس تتعرض لما تتعرض اليه لواء
فايز الدويري وقد انقطعت الاتصالات
والانترنت الان على خان
يونس مقال البارحه في صحيفه يدعو ت احرنوت
ماذا يقول يقول يدخل الجيش الاسرائيلي الى
خان يونس من دون خطه لليوم التالي للحرب
وهذا جيد لعمليه انتقاميه وليس لتحرك يجب
ان يخدم هدفا استراتيجيا من الناحيه
العسكريه يعني هل هل نقبل انه جيش نظامي
عصري متطور يدخل هكذا لقطاع غزه يخبط خبط
عشوائي الى هذه الدرجه ليس قادرا على
اداره معركه في النهايه امام مليشيات حماس
ليست لا جيش نظامي لا الجيش المصري ولا
السوري سابقا ولا العراقي سابقا ي يعني
هناك معضله على الصعيد على الصعيد الميدان
القتالي استاذ محمد انا لم يعني لم اقرا
هذا المقال ولكن تحدثت بالامس وقلت تصوري
لمعركه غزه سيتم تجزئتها هي هي المرحله
الثانيه على المستوى الاستراتيجي لكن سيتم
تجزئتها الى ثلاثه مراحل لكن في هذه
الحاله وفي حاله هذا الهجوم ستتوقف القوات
الاسرائيليه بعد المرحله الاولى لعدم
ادراكك ما هي المرحله الثانيه وبالتالي س
تنبثق المرحله الثانيه من نتائج المرحله
الاولى وهذا نوع من التخطيط الاعمى عندما
لا يدرك الانسان ما هي يعني في اي تخطيط
يجب ان اربط الاهداف
بالامكانات في حال ضبابيه المشهد انا هنا
تخطيطي اعمى وهذا ما عبرت عنه بالامس
وانسجم مع ما جاء في التقرير هي ذهبت
بدافع بدافع الفشل في الشمال تبحث عن نصر
في الجنوب ليس اكثر من ذلك الان المعركه
مختلفه معطيات الميدان مختلفه طريقه اداره
المعركه مختلفه لا يوجد اهداف هل هذا ما
يفسر التجاء مثلا لطائرات استطلاعيه
بريطانيه يقال انها الان تحوم حول غزه
لتساعدها في تحديد اين اين يمكن ان يكون
الرهائن يعني لجوءها الى مساعدات غربيه
بريطانيه في هذه الحاله على الاقل بشكل
واضح ل في اداره العمليه صحيح انها ليست
طائرات قتاليه ولكنها طائرات تقوم بجهد
حربي في زاويه ما سيدي دعني اشير الى نقطه
في
عجاله كان هناك فشل استخباراتي اسرائيلي
في سابع من اكتوبر في المستوى الاستراتيجي
والعمليات
والتعبوي اذا هناك فشل هذا الفشل لابد من
اغلاق ثغراته انا قرات في اكث من اكثر من
مصدر بان هناك غرفه العمليات سواء في تل
ابيب او في القاعده التجسسيه في غلاف غزه
يوجد بها ضباط استخبارات من اكثر من دوله
هكذا قرائت ل لم تصدر عن جهات الرسميه لكن
العديد من الواقع تحمل درجه مصداقيه ضباط
استخبارات امريكيين
بريطانيين المان فرنسيين ايطاليين من خمسه
دول يوجد ضباط استخبارات اي بمعنى اخر كان
غزه تحارب العالم الكل موجود الاقمار
الصناعيه الطائرات المسيره جميعها من اجل
ترميم ترميم ما حدث في السابع من اكتوبر
وهذا الترميم هو للمنظومه الاستخباريه
الاسرائيليه واقر الشين بيت وغير الشين
بيت بفشلهم الذريع اذا هذا التواجد اصبح
حتميا لا بل هناك تواجد اعلى الم ترسل
امريكا قوات الم ترسل امريكا حاملات الم
ترسل ري ستار جنرال يساعد في اداره
المعركه والتخطيط اذا دعني اقول الغرب يقف
مع اسرائيل في كل المجالات من اجل اعاده
ترميم الهيبه الاسرائيليه ولكن اعتقد ان
الهيبه الاسرائيليه كما عندما يكسر لوح من
الزجاج من الصعب ان يلتهم خان يونس دكتور
هلس وهي تتعرض لما تتعرض اليه الان
الان الامور وصلت الى حد توقف تقديم
المساعدات حسب المتحدث باسم الامين العام
للامم المتحده المساعدات التي كانت توزع
وان كانت محدوده الان توقفت لان الاعمال
القتاليه والعدائين كما وصفها ما زالت
مستمره هذا اللجوء الى الدعم الغربي اشرنا
الى الطائرات الاستطلاع البريطانيه كيف هو
صداه في الاوساط ال الاسرائيليه لان من
بين ما كتب ايضا في الصحافه الاسرائيليه
ان علينا كاسرائيل بعد هذه المعركه ان
نعول اكثر على انفسنا في الصناعه الحربيه
وفي كل التقنيات الحربيه وكان اسرائيل
تقول هذا الامتحان اظهر ان لدينا ثغرات
على مستوى
التسليح اولا يعني دعونا لا ننكر بان
اسرائيل هي راس حربه هذا الغرب وعلى راس
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا وفرنسا
والمانيا هي مشروعهم وهي صورتهم اي هذه
كلها انظمه استعماريه استعمرت وقتلت
واحتلت وجزء منها ما زال يستعمر ويحتل
ويقتل وبالتالي الرعايه التي حضيت بها
اسرائيل منذ انشاء هذا الكيان تستمر لانه
في الضرب في هيبه هذا الكان وفي صوره هذا
الكان هي ضرب في المنظومه الاستعماريه ككل
هم حرصوا على تفوق اسرائيل التقني والنوعي
ولا يمكن في اوج هذه الهزه التي تتعرض لها
اسرائيل ان يتركوا اسرائيل منطقي جدا في
اطار هذه العلاقه ان يحضر الغرب بقده وقض
بمساعدته وان يقف مع اسرائيل اسرائيل تدرك
هذه المساله وهي اصلا تفهم انه لولا
الرعايه الغربيه ولولا الغطاء التي توفره
الولايات المتحده تحديدا لاسرائيل في كل
المحافل الدبلوماسي السياسي الدولي لما
كان هناك شيء اسمه اسرائيل يعني كل هذه
الهزه التي تعرضت لها اسرائيل من القله
قليله جدا استدعت ان يحضر الغرب بقوته
كامله يعني اسرائيل هذه المقاوم لا تقارع
اسرائيل وحدها هذه المقاومه تقارع منظومه
دوليه كامله تقارع الغرب باعلام
بمنظومتها بغطاء القانوني على اسرائيل
الجزء من الاسرائيليين يدرك بانه الحاجه
الى الولايات المتحده هي حلاجه ملحه وذلك
يعني نتنياهو وبعض القيادات السياسيه
العقلانيه في النظام السياسي الاسرائيلي
يفهمون انه بعض الاصوات والصراخ
الاسرائيلي مثل بينغ فير لما قال في موقف
معين سابقا قبل الاحداث السابع من اكتوبر
اننا اسنا النجمه 56 في عالم الولايات
المتحده اسكتوا بعض الاصوات وطرحوا معطيات
تتعلق بطبيعه المساعدات الماليه
والاقتصاديه والعسكريه التي تدقها
الولايات المتحده لاسرائيل تمكينها من من
الصمود وبذلك اسرائيل دون غم ذلك ومع ذلك
دكتور هلس تخرج بين الحين والاخر تصريحات
امريكيه مثل التي نقراها في الخبر العاجل
عن الخارجيه الامريكيه بانه من المبكر
اجراء تقييم نهائي لما ابدته اسرائيل من
تعاون فيما يتعلق ب
تجنب اصابه المدنيين يبدو ان القلق
الامريكي بين قوسين في هذا الموضوع مازال
مستمر هناك ايضا مساله اخرى دكتور هلسه لو
سمحت لي هل هل جزء من التخبط الاسرائيلي
او على الاقل الشعور بعدم السيطره الكامله
على الوضع هذه التصريحات التي تطلق عن
ضروره القيام باغتيال لقاده حماس اين موجد
سواء في قطر او في تركيا او في اي مكان
وهذا ردت عليه تركيا بشكل واضح لتحذير
المخابرات الاسرائيليه
المساد من من مثل هذا التصرف هناك ايضا
حديث عن ساعود في الموضوع هذا مع الدكتور
مع اللواء فايز الدويري موضوع تصريحات
تتعلق بضروره انشاء منطقه عازله ولكن دعنا
نتوقف قليلا على الاقل مع هذه التصريحات
هل هي جزء من الارتباك
الاسرائيلي هي جزء من التخويف والتهويه
الاسرائيلي اي ربما تعبر عن ارباك لكنها
مقصوده
يعني النظام الامني الاسرائيلي المؤسسه
الامنيه الاسرائيليه بشقيها المساد
والمخابرات الاسرائيليه حينما تود وتضع
خطط لتنفيذ اغتيالات ضد مقاومين ضد عرب او
فلسطينيين لا تلجا الى الحديث عن هذا
الامر ولا تلجا حتى الى التسريب بهذه
الطريقه عن هذا الامر ربما ياتي في السياق
بعض المواقف الداخليه المناكفات الداخليه
خاصه بانه يعني نتنياهو قيل بانه طرح
عليهم حرض عليه في مواقف سابقه ان يغتال
صالح العرور او بعض القيادات او حسن نصر
الله لكنه تراجع ربما تاتي هذه المواقف
لاحراج نتنياهو ومحاوله تعريته خاصه في ظل
يعني حاله الاستعداء التي يشعر بها من جزء
من اركان الكابينت والحكومه الاسرائيليه
والفضاء الاسرائيلي السياسي العام لكنها
ايضا تاتي في سياق الحرب النفسيه التي
تشنها اسرائيل ليس فقط على اعدائه انما في
جزء منه على يعني اي الحاضنه التيم تحاول
ان تخفف مما يجري وتتوسط لما يجري تركيا
مثلا موقفها ليس
متماهية اك على صعيد التصريحات مثل ما
اشرنا الى تصريح الخارجيه الامريكيه هناك
ايضا تصريح اخر لواء فايز الدويري وهناك
ايضا مفارقات حتى في الموقف الامريكي تقول
بانها لاحظت بعض التغيير في سير العمليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه في الجنوب تختلف عن
الشمال في حين ان حصيله اصابه المدنيين
مرتفعه ربما اكثر حتى من الشمال يعني ا
اين هو التغيير الذي شهدته واشنطن هو
التغيير في شكل في شكل المناوره وطبيعه
المع مركه لانه المعطيات على الارض مختلفه
عندما نتحدث عن الشمال نتحدث عن مدينه
متكامله ممتده عندما يعني اذا تحدثنا عن
اي حي حتى لو تحدثنا عن بيت حانون متصل مع
غزه نتحدث اذا بينما في الجنوب لا الجنوب
هناك مسافات بينيه متباعده ما بين مدن
المركز والبلدات المحيطه فبالتالي طبيعه
المعركه يفرضها الواقع الجغرافي
والديموغرافي على ارض المعركه ليس بسبب
تغير الاهداف
الان عمليه الاجرام والتدمير والقتل انا
تحدثت منذ اليوم الاول ان المرحله الثانيه
هي اوسع اوسع اطارا واكثر اجراما واكثر
دمويه وهذا ما يجري الان مع ذلك الخارجيه
الامريكيه ايضا تقول راينا اسرائيل وهي
تصدر طلبات اكثر تحديدا لعمليات الاخلاف
في جنوب قطاع غزه يعني هذا اشاره رضا بشكل
او باخر ان كان اسرائيل اكثر انسانيه هذه
المره في لا
الرد واضح
1.9 من اصل 2.2 مليون نازح الان
1.9 نازحين الان تم الحديث للمنطقه
الشماليه ان تنزح الى المنطقه الجنوبيه تم
مطالبه سكان غزه بالذهاب الى رفح هناك
بعدين البعد الاول يطالب باعاده التوطين
والثاني يطالب بانشاء منطقه عازله نعم
هناك ايضا فكره ننهي بها هذه الح
هناك بدا الترويج في بعض التعاليق الصحف
الاسرائيليه من بينهم البارحه صحيفه اردز
مقال لكاتب اسرائيلي اسمه تسيفي برئيل
يتحدث عن ضروره منطقه عازله بين قطاع غزه
وا اسرائيل ويقول بان هذه الفكره ليست
جديده تركيا لديها منطقه عازله مع سوريا
مصر لديها منطقه عازله مع مع غزه في في
صحراء سيناء وبالتالي نحن سنفعل نفس الشيء
يا سيدي انا قلت لك هناك بعدين البعد
الاول المتطرفين او اكث الجميع متطرف
الاكثر تطرفا يتحدث عن اعاده توطين بينما
الاقل تطرف يتحدث عن بفر زون الان ما هي
مساحه زحت عند انت تضرب سوريا مثال سوريا
وتركيا نتحدث عن دول ومساحه انا اتحدث عن
362 م مربع لا يعقل ان يكون هناك منطقه
عاجله نعم ننهي ايضا بهذا الخبر العاجل
الخارجيه الامريكيه تقول مع ذلك ما زلنا
نتوقع للاسف كما تقول سقوط مدنيين نتيجه
العمليه العسكريه ولكن تضيف وهذا صحيح
للاسف في جميع الحروب وكان الامر هذا ليس
تعليقا مني ولكن يبدو الامر وكانه نوع من
التبرير لما لما يجري بهذا نصل الى نهايه
هذه الحلقه